my eyes are even watering big be careful
oh yeah that's right Jesus hey what's
going on everybody from first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings today I'm joined by
Jim Gaffigan batad season two of the Jim
Gaffigan show returns the TV land on
Sundays it's coming to a city near you
with the fully dressed tour this summer
welcome to the show Jim well thank you
for having me I you know in my show
there's always a point in the process
where we ask the question what is Jim
eating in the sink because I'm eating in
every scene what about this what are you
thinking on this one I'm a little
nervous but this is I'm a man I can
handle this all right
ready to do this we say grace first
sriracha no big deal plus you're a food
guy so you know what's up does that code
for your fat
I feel like sriracha it's so big now
it's strange it's like the coconut water
of hot tub what do you think of it it's
right I like it it's also it I feel like
it's gonna peak and disappear it's gonna
be like bell-bottoms we're gonna be like
remember sriracha so I know that you
were kind of a high school football star
and ended up playing at Georgetown I was
alignment I look like a lineman not in
your picture you look like oh well I
look like good job yeah you look exactly
like Greg Olson actually my assistant
saw a photo of me and went around that
time and he just looked at me he said
what happened I said food happened how
would you describe your game on a scale
from Little Giants to Friday Night
Lights the weird thing is is like I you
know I was an athlete but in acting I
always get roles of like nerdy people so
I'm always cast as a nerd and often when
I'll meet people on the street they'll
be like you're bigger than I thought
like people think that I'm gonna be this
really wimpy guy I noticed Joe Gaffigan
also on the roster at that that's bright
play with your brother
I quit the football team when my brother
was the captain and I quit before I told
him and he was not happy I didn't fit
the personality of the football player
but uh I guess Ari I don't know I don't
know if I fit a type I'm very good
looking he did stand-up comedy for Pope
Francis no well I opened for the
popemobile I did stand-up then Sister
Sledge went on and then the popemobile
came in did a lab and the Pope opted out
did his bed
how does that experience differ from say
shooting a Netflix special at the Vic
theater it was a completely ridiculous
experience people were going there to
see the Pope and I was gonna do stand-up
beforehand so it made no sense
whatsoever and so I'm kind of I tried to
address it saying look I know after my
set you're probably gonna want to leave
but you should stick around see the Pope
it was a no-win situation but I couldn't
turn it down okay this is too hard for
me oh I'm gonna die am I gonna die
so I want to give you some food
head-to-head since you're kind of the
food god I'm just Coast versus West
Coast cuz it's very good interest Shake
Shack in and out so that's a good
question
I love in and out but that's like the
high school girlfriend and then Shake
Shack is the woman I'll spend the rest
of my life with but that being said I've
been you know in LA doing press and I've
gone to in and out at like 10:00 a.m.
like we're not even making burgers yet
and I'm like I'll wait Chipotle versus
Kate Oba
that's no comparison I mean so like the
idea is that people just can't do the
interview right it's a brilliant concept
how is that via on the other side cuz I
don't really know what it's like it's
almost kind of like a manufactured flop
sweat windy is first start doing
stand-up you're like I'm sweating my
tongue swollen and it's like I haven't
felt that in a long time
how about a subway versus Jimmy John's
Jimmy John's is beyond better than a
subway okay first of all subway is kind
of corporate and Jimmy John's has Jimmy
John it's a romantic story of a guy who
went a University of Illinois and I went
to open the sandwich shop and now he's
like he's a white trash hero are you
from Illinois yeah you were born in
Elgin right I was born in Elgin where
are you from I was born in Evanston and
then I spent quite a bit of time in
Crystal Lake North West burbs you
familiar with that one I would lived in
Barrington for a little bit and then I
moved to Indiana my parents met at
Barrington high school no way yeah did
you ever go to Hackney's Hackney's with
the burgers with the burger with the rye
yeah yeah yeah that's a great restaurant
yen loan always get the onion loaf that
was my best removed like when I was a
little kid we'd go to Northwestern games
yeah and then on the way home we'd stop
at Hackney's that's right and my dad was
like you always got to get the onion
that's right that's right
hey we got we go together
look it even looks like it's an injured
baby yeah
be careful with this one all right
really all right you know one of the
many pitfalls of being a father and I
know you have five kids is that you have
to endure a lot of horrible movies and a
lot of horrible TV shows yes a lot of
entertainment that's horrible my dad
used to have to do the same thing but
there were two shows that he low-key
kind of liked even if he wouldn't admit
it to us yeah now is where Pete and Pete
a Nickelodeon and he liked elf what are
the shows that your kids make you watch
that should be horrible kid shows but
that you low-key actually kind of like I
don't think it's that bold of me to say
that spongebob it's good
spongebob is good right I mean the irony
is you'll be watching something with
your kids
that you don't want to watch and they'll
walk away doing other stuff and you'll
just sit there and you're like I'm
watching Jesse it's pretty bad so this
is the point where you just see someone
coming undone right and I'm like not
even halfway through you automatically
go all the way through automatically but
you've had practice but like does a
boxer feel punches in the face less just
because he boxes more I think so
brown boys I would say definitely yes
yeah this is a delightful one the hot
ones you like it it's good this weed it
that would be a good one to eat while
you watch the Jim Gaffigan show Sunday
night and 9:00 and um so you made a name
for yourself with all the hilarious
observations that you've made about junk
food but people shouldn't get it twisted
because you've really traveled the
country and hit some of the best
regional spots in the United States and
what are some of the things that bother
you about restaurants or chefs or
foodies I would rather get a hometown
special than a super high-end restaurant
like you know here's a quail egg and a
beam the restaurants that are the
regional favorites you don't really see
them with Michelin stars all that often
but then the restaurants that are price
fix with guys doing chemistry
experiments yeah those rack them up the
super-rich are always hiding they always
want to be by themselves and so they
establish country clubs and then they go
over here and they do this or that and
so some of these restaurants that are
like super fancy are not any better than
other ones they just wanna a group where
they can be around rich people anyone
I'm a great guy can't bring you on hot
ones without asking you about hot
pockets I know the hot pockets Rutina
change your life I've never eaten a hot
Park and then afterwards been I'm glad I
hate that I'm always like I'm gonna die
probably get asked about it in every
interview that's a quarter right we
interviewed a guy
Versace Pop Tarts aka thought pocket aka
the guy who was kicked off a vine or
making love to a hot pocket
how'd you smack that interview that
exclusive I believe we didn't win a
Pulitzer and all of your hot pocket
interviews is this story ever touched
your radar ya know about the guy having
sex with our pockets yeah every single
thing that's happened to a hot pocket
gets tweeted at me like people will go
into a grocery store and they'll be
walking by about hot pockets and they'll
tweet a photo like I'm dying to know
every update and it's the same with
bacon but it's fun it's like
mmm is there any part of you that
understands where this guy's coming from
Versace pop making rub too hard yeah
look I'm a comedian who goes on stage
and seeks the approval of strangers but
that's a pretty desperate move was he
popular on so he would like have sex
like a box of pop-tarts and that's how
we'd get like followers like was it this
wasn't the only food Billy hi pocket was
just the straw that broke the camel's
back with vine that's the threshold that
vine established you know Pop Tarts who
hasn't gone there but a hot pocket come
on that's the food of Champions so he
did he do this
did he make love to me no no no we
didn't have him on this show no I mean
either King you can't he can't get him
hey my tongue is like three times the
size it normally is what is are you
ahead of me now so I just took a bite
out of this it's called pain really does
anyone ever quit so we've had three
people quit who are they they were Tony
Yayo is a rap reason g-unit DJ Khaled
you know dj khaled similar to me yeah
and my caps yeah he quit really at seven
all right I got funny for my god all
right so I was at an audition in Queens
and my caps was there and he was like
kilos hey can I have a dollar and I go
yeah he goes for the subway if I go yeah
sure so then like six months later I see
him doing stand-up and he goes why
people will just give you a dollar just
go up to a white person it's hit give me
a dollar and they will give you a dime
and I was like Jesus Christ that's me
that's hilarious how bad is this to me
it's like the worst not making me want
to do it my sales pitch isn't actually
there you like Chicago I do like Chicago
I like Chicago I like the food in
Chicago Chicago deep-dish
I know Chicagoans do if you were to pick
a deep-dish place what would you go with
would you go with Geno's or you go with
little Malnati's
I know who knows Abhi's Lou Malnati's
that's my favorite too do you have an
opinion cuz it pops up all the time on
the New York very cago thing
well I pick Chicago I do I mean I don't
think there's really any comparison
though I always think that they're so
different that there is no comparison
and I'm always with New York I'm like
all right that like thin pizza that's
always oily that you can get like three
slices for a dollar plug the can of
spray compare that to what you get in
Chicago like they're pretty more hours
but then again you have to wait four
hours for the Chicago deep-dish it's
worth it yeah okay so this is the bomb
you know a lot of people credit you for
better or for worse for thinking about
Dunkin Donuts in other words donut
breakfast sandwich and you're kind of
willing that into reality flattery but I
think you look at some of the fast food
products it's inevitable in there
there's literally oh are you kidding me
that's not even real how about have you
tried red Robins ramen burger they have
the ramen instead of the bun that's
wrong that's a sin against humanity
God is not happy with that ah all right
now I think I'm getting Punk'd
unnecessary unnecessary [ __ ] why
that's a fair question to ask us and I'm
not sure I have a great answer it's not
going away that's unnecessary
all right all right you're fired
that's just unnecessary Jim are you out
I'm out [ __ ] this thing nothing will
stop here boom I'm human I can't not do
anything I'm done man I can't do nobody
I'm a quitter well I'll keep going cuz I
think I have two more questions for you
you don't feel it at all no I do but I
feel a sense of responsibility you know
there's a vertical who watch this show I
think they would be let down if I didn't
take it all the way to the house you
know what I mean
no no the house take it to the house
you're eating wings
does anyone have like a bowl of mashed
potatoes or something so the word dad
it's become such a buzzword and popular
culture their dad jokes their dad bods
their dad shoes on Twitter people call
their favorite celebrities dad and I
feel like you've been kind of carrying
the dad brand for quite some time but
right now it seems like dad's the
50-meter at dads
they're not with dads the reality is is
that there's nothing cool about your
parents right even if you like them
there's nothing cool about them until
you become a parent then you're like oh
all right I mean we're dismissive of dad
you know like I said I don't really care
but it's a little bit like I don't know
if it's serving us does that make sense
yeah it does do you have any kids
no I don't not you know right
that's a dad joke
Megadeath sauce with liquid rage made by
Blair's the hottest sauce we have where
if it made Highlands New Jersey that's
where you make sauces right it's kind of
tradition around here to dab the last
wing I'm gonna do that so that's made
with what poison you think goes through
in here don't do it will cause anus to
bleed
please use with extreme caution all
right well here's my Katrina washing its
novelty there's no one sitting at home
I'm going honey grab the Megadeth sauce
I'm making some pasta I hope not makes
no sense like this whole thing's
ridiculous and this is a lot it's the
most I've ever done at oh wow how often
do you get told you look like Peter
Sarsgaard never but I'll take it
my cap said I looked like Smeagol from
Lord of the Rings get Neil Patrick
Harris sometimes I'll take that one
alright so weird of just blood started
coming down it might happen that could
happen right you're such a calm and
gregarious guy but I'm sure you know
somebody who spends as much time on the
road as you do in traffic and in
airports there has to be a lot of rage
oh that's you know I mean I love living
in New York but it's a there's a
different timing and different parts of
the country like you'll go in and you'll
be like hey I'd like to get something
and people are just having a
conversation you're like I'm in a
drugstore I just want to buy this and
get out of here this isn't my only human
interaction for the day they're just
like how y'all doing and you're like I
don't want to talk to you I just want to
get my diarrhea medication and get out
of it the you know it should go like
this and then the last one should be
pepto Jim we did it I did it you did it
I'm a little impressed I'm glad that I
stopped
I'm glad cuz I have other things to do
today besides sitting on the toilet
yelling this is like a food concussion
like I quit the NFL before I got yours
really everyone is just like he's our
time why would he hang up the cleats I
got some money I don't need to have CTE
let the people know but you have going
on in your life well I just want to
reach
tell everyone oh you mean the show yeah
yeah maybe the Jim Gaffigan show is on
TV land and then a tree airs on Comedy
Central
set your damn DVR I'm gonna take some
plug too and I'm gonna take this time to
address something that I see in the
comments every once awhile
oh this it's a fake show the sauces
aren't actually on the wings all those
different things Jim can you just tell
the people these are these were real
distinctive different flavors
most of them horrible but they were
authentic and you
I mean you are part satanic that's why
you can do it right that's not a skill
that's not that's just sticking food in
your mouth all right take it from a guy
who makes a living eating but I was
impressed I think that you're a better
man than me thank you and I'm proud of
myself for it Jim thank you coming in
appreciate